[Music]
let's start this lesson by defining
process QL structured query language or
SQL is a generic database language that
helps to communicate with databases the
park SQL is the base SAS implementation
of SQL it allows you to retrieve
summarized sort join and concatenate
datasets or databases available in SAS
proc SQL is used for the following
generate reports and summary statistics
retrieve and combine data from tables
create tables views and indexes update
and retrieve data from DBMS modify a
podcast ql table by adding modifying or
dropping columns the prog SQL allows you
to combine the functionality of the data
step and the product step into a single
step before we begin with the concepts
of prog SQL let's understand some
terminologies associated with the
product SQL the following table lists
the equivalent terms that are used in
SQL SAS and data processing the proc SQL
table is termed as SAS data file and SAS
and file and data processing the row in
SQL has termed in observation and SAS
and record in data processing the column
in SQL is termed a variable incest and
field and data processing
well let's now learn the syntax of proc
SQL and its uses
let's step into the syntax classroom to
learn the syntax of SQL
the proc SQL command begins with the
keyword proc SQL and ends with the
keyword quit the keyword quit is used to
terminate the procedure
in this demo you'll learn how to
retrieve data from a table using the
proc SQL clauses
in this demo we'll retrieve data of all
the products from the electronic data
set which have sum of sales greater than
450 in a descending order the data set
electronic is imported to the SAS
console using the code shown on the
screen to achieve data using proc SQL
clauses use the keyword proc SQL prog
SQL execute the program without using
the run statement the columns product
sales and order priority are selected
from the table electronic using the
keyword select
in this demo the products that have sale
rather than 200 are selected using the
where statement the group by statement
is used to group data by a specific
column here we will group the product
column with the group by clause we can
also use an aggregate function in the
Select clause or in a having clause in
this demo the products which have the
sum of sales greater than 450 are
grouped
note that the aggregate function sum is
used here
the keyword quit is used to terminate
the procedure
this concludes the demo on how to
retrieve from a table using the proc SQL
clauses at times you'll need to select
all columns or a specific column in a
table to select all columns in a table
use an asterisk symbol in the Select
clause to select a specific column in a
table use the column name in the Select
clause using proc SQL you can also
eliminate the duplicate rows from the
output data to do so use the keyword
distinct in the Select Clause proc SQL
allows you to create a new variable in
the query result these columns can
either be text or calculations you can
add text column to the query result by
using a string or literal expression
take a look at this example program and
its output data set shown on the screen
here a new column bonus is created where
observations are derived from the sale
column the generated output is shown on
the screen you can also change the
format of the variable and assign a new
label to the data set in this example
the attribute is used to modify the
format of the sales variable and the
label is used to name the output data
set the generated output is shown on the
screen
proc SQL also allows you to process
conditional data case expression as a
valid SQL expression that resolves to a
table column where the values are
compared to all the wind conditions
using case expression in the Select
Clause you can extract the data that
fulfills the set condition the generated
output data set is shown on the screen
in this example from the electronic data
set the product and discount column are
selected and the condition is set to the
sales column the end statement is
required in the case expression also set
the condition in descending order to
increase the efficiency because class
stops checking the case expression as
soon as it finds the first true value
the output data set is shown here note
that the column order priority 1 is
generated
calculated enables you to use the
results of an expression in the same
select cause or in the where cause let's
take the previous example and derive net
profit to derive net profit create a tax
column which is 5% of the sales amount
and subtract tax from the profit you
must use the calculated keyword with the
alias to inform proc SQL that the value
is calculated within the query otherwise
the SQL code will fail with the method
similar to column tax was not found the
generated output is shown on the screen
using SAS you can also obtain the totals
by order Priority One
look at the example shown on the screen
the sum function returns the sum of each
row of the columns specified as
arguments the count returns the total
number of rows in the group or in a
table the generated output is shown on
the screen the SQL procedure passed
through facility communicates with the
DBMS through the SAS access engine the
pass through facility allows you to do
the following pass native DBMS SQL
statements to a DBMS display the query
results formatted as a report create SAS
data files and views from query results
since the database is typically
optimized and indexed to handle queries
complex joins are handled much faster
with the SQL pass-through query take a
look at the example program shown on the
screen use keyword connect to link the
DBMS
using the create table statement you can
create a new table to define the columns
and their attributes you can also
specify a columns name type length
format and label let's understand with
an example in this example the
electronic example data set is created
this data set will have the data from
the electronic data set that has higher
order priority the second select
statement is used to show the complete
electronic data set note that only one
table is created using the create table
statement the generated outputs are
shown on the screen
so far you have learned how to retrieve
data from a single table now let's learn
how to retrieve data from multiple
tables if you want to combine multiple
tables through SAS code it requires
several proc sort data step and emerge
function however using proc SQL multiple
data sets are combined easily to select
data from multiple tables simply join
the tables in a query let's step into
the syntax classroom to learn the syntax
for selecting two tables using proc SQL
use the keyboard select to select the
table the asterisk symbol selects all
the columns from tables 1 & 2 to select
the particular column from table simply
mention the column name after the
keyword select
let's now learn how to select data from
multiple tables the data that you may
need for research can come from
different sources to combine them join
the tables in a query there are two
types of joins inner join and outer join
the inner join selects all rows from
both tables as long as there is a match
between the columns in both tables the
outer join returns all matching records
from both tables whether the outer table
matches or not let's learn about each
type of join in detail the inner join
selects all rows from both tables as
long as there is a match between the
columns in both tables it can combine a
maximum of 256 tables at a time only
rows that satisfy the join conditions
are kept let's step into the syntax
classroom to see the syntax
you can't perform
by using a list of table names separated
by commas with the where clause or by
using the inner join and on keywords
let's take an example of how we can join
electronic and electronic customer info
datasets to attach customer name and
customer ID to each other you can select
columns from both tables with asterik
and utilize the feedback option you can
use the feedback option to see exactly
how proc SQL is implementing your query
in the log session you can see all
column names with E and C table aliases
the output obtained is shown on the
screen you can also customize your query
by selecting only required columns in
the order you prefer observe the changes
made in the code to select preferred
columns the output obtained is shown on
the screen
you can obtain the same results by
performing an inner join with where
clause and inner join and on keywords
both approaches are used interchangeably
in practice the output obtained is shown
on the screen
in contrast with an inner join and outer
join keeps rows that match the condition
as well as some or all of the unmatched
data from one or both tables now there
are three types of outer joins
left-right and full the left join
returns all rows from the left table or
table one with the matching rows in the
right table or table to the electronic
data set and electronic customer
information data set is taken as an
example the output for the example
program is shown on the screen the right
join returns all rows from the right
table or table to with the matching rows
in the left table or table one the
electronic data set and electronic
customer information data set is taken
as an example the output for the example
program is shown on the screen
the full outer join returns all rows
from the left table or table one and
from the right table table to the
electronic data set and electronic
customer information data set are taken
as an example the output for the example
program is shown on the screen
and concatenate the two query results
using the Union operator Union operator
takes unique observations from the data
set and generates a report
remember that Union does not return
duplicate rows if a row occurs more than
once then only one occurrence is
returned sometimes you need to return
duplicate rows as well in this case you
can use the keyword Union all which
requires that duplicate rows remain in
the output you can also concatenate two
or more query results using the operator
except intersect and outer Union use the
operator except to produce rows that are
part of the first query only use the
operator intersect to produce rows that
are common to both queries use the
operator outer Union to concatenate the
query results
how to concatenate the query results
using the operator Union
two datasets namely north and south are
imported to the sass console in this
demo we'll would concatenate the two
datasets using the operator Union the
table output is created using the
keyword create
the variables order ID region and sales
amount have been selected from the data
set north and south using the keyword
select
you
the keyword union is used to can
two datasets the union operator produces
all unique rows from both queries
you
note that the variables selected in both
the datasets are the same the keyword
quit is used to terminate the procedure
you
this concludes the demo on how to
concatenate the query results using the
operator union hey once you become an
expert in Big Data then subscribe to the
simply learn Channel and click here to
watch more such videos sinnard up and
get certified in Big Data click here